Memorial Day? A national holiday to
celebrate those who have died in service.
so thank you for those that have served
and those who have passed away. Memorial Day?
My favorite thing about it? That's an
awkward question. Cause everybody will just
say the time off that they get on Memorial
Day but reality everyone should be taking
the time to kind of think about people
that have put in a lot of work and
sacrifice into getting us the life that
we have today.
I think Memorial Day is a good day to
think about people or grandparents
served in the military. That's kind of stuff I
think about Memorial Day. You'll find
me at the barbecue for sure. Wherever
there's a grill I will bring meat and
cook on it. You know, that's my way of
celebrating is getting together, taking
that day of relaxation and good food
and fellowship and hanging out. Giving thanks to
those people. You know? That's what I feel. In the service. You know? To make us be able to do
what we get to do in life. My grandpa
was in the 2nd Armored Division in World
War II in the European theater and then
my other grandfather was stateside doing
maintenance and working on planes. A lot
of my family's been Marine or Air Force.
My grandfather was a mix, whatever that is.
The main ship the battleship.
Interesting story: my grandfather was
drafted in World War II after he was
thirty. Within a month, the law was passed
that no one over 30 would be drafted. My
other grandfather on the Pacific was in
an amphibious unit of the army. When he came
back after the war, he worked at a TV
station and then worked for the space
program in communications, so that's pretty cool!
Did you have any family members? Memorial Day?
In World War I,
my mom's great-uncle he was a Doughboy
and was gassed on the front lines and he
came back and he kind of lost his mental
capacity and, you know, dealt with all
sorts of diseases and then passed away. You
know, share the stories of those people
and remember them I think there's
honor than that you know. Enjoying
the freedom that they gave us? Yeah, I mean we
do it every day. Look at this! You have
the freedom to sit around making YouTube
videos every day. We don't have to, like,
work in mines. Gotcha. What?
I got you. You didn't even hear me say "Gotcha". Really? How did you get me?
You said the "m-word".